it's the great Star Trek Legacy lie it's
the LIE they told it to Strange New
worlds we are getting Legacy and one of
the actors has come out recently and
basically said as much welcome to SRE
your ccii TV and movie
channel so I did a video uh last week
talking about how there was an agreement
now between um Paramount and Amazon on
how to Star Trek Legacy I got called a
liar several times by people that have
actually worked on the show Even though
those people didn't actually watch the
video and one of the things I have
actually now been saying for a year is
that Star Trek Legacy was always going
to happen helmet goes without saying to
ignore everything he just said I usually
do it was matter of when not if why do I
say that because par out have done it
before and secret hideout let's actually
blame secret hideout yeah let's do that
secret hideout have done it
before so with strange new worlds that
was touted by the creators of secret
Hider and Paramount this big fan success
they did the second season of um Star
Trek Discovery we had the enterprise we
had Pike we had this whole crew we had
new actors playing Spock Etc we then got
about a two-year Gap but in that time
there was this massive campaign the
campaign was to get strange new worlds
and then when it was green lit it was
hailed as a success of the
fans secret hideout who has not got the
best reputation let's be honest were
able to throw up the hands and go you
wanted it then we're going to give it
you because we love you we love you
trekkies please stop hating Alex
curtzman we're giving you strange new
worlds now it did work strange new
worlds has been very popular and it has
not harmed secret hideout or Paramount's
reputation but they're doing it again
bunch of near duells and Rule Breakers
really I could possibly go wrong does
anybody really think that Paramount and
secret hideout would have allowed Terry
metalis to do so much development work
and to set up and to tease Star Trek
Legacy in the way he did if they didn't
intend to do the series in the same way
that do you really think they actually
set up season two of Discovery with
Captain Pike this actor that actually
was already very popular at the time to
actually go as far as designing a new
set of the
Enterprise creating a new digital
version of the Enterprise Etc and to go
through so much effort of setting up
that series not to do it they're not
complete
morons
mostly so of course the plan was always
to do Star Trek Legacy and now thanks to
cyrek dropping another exclusive on your
asses I can tell you that a plan is in
place on how to fund it because that
really is the only problem for secret
hideout and P out right now paying for
it
but which actors come out and actually
spoken about this and what did they say
Michelle herd plays rafy a character
that I don't mind this is an actress
actually that's been in a few things
I've watched over the last few years I
didn't really know much about it five
years ago so but she's done a few things
and she's a good actress the character
is a bit all over place to me at times
but it's very cool she's going to be
seven of ninees number one but what has
she said in an interview in the last few
days if if you're enjoying the video
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
thumbs up leave a comment and all those
things but also go and check us out on
patreon.com Sidetrack most of our videos
do premere there first this video
actually premiered nearly 10 hours
before it did on YouTube and a lot of
our videos actually Premier 24 hours
before they do on YouTube so go over
check that out I love rafie she's my
favorite character herd explained we
have our hands fingers everything cost
for Star Trek Legacy I know that right
now they're working on section 31 for
Michelle yo yes that is filming right
now and then they're going to be doing
starle Academy Star Trek 90210 yeah I'm
really excited about that yay spin-off
from
Discovery um and then if the fans still
want it they'll start working on Star
Trek
Legacy if the fans still want it they'll
start working on Star Trek
Legacy now that is insane if the fans
still want it they might do Legacy or
something else that's basically taking
the party line Paramount want to again
sell Star Trek Legacy as them listening
to the fans and it will be a huge treky
success we're doing this because we love
you we love you trekkies please stop
hating Alex
curtzman this is a subtle plan but it's
obvious and if anybody out there really
believes the Star Trek Legacy isn't
planned and hasn't been planned for two
years you really need to look at what
power Mountain secret hideout have done
before this is quite a clever plan in
lots of ways because in lots of ways
trekkies don't like Alex kursman the
Star Trek fandom is very divided and
this is a way to bring it together but
there might be a problem Terry metalis
is hailed as the man that brought us
become season
3 H set a course the metalis system
maximum warp tactical ready Torpedoes
and faces he is hailed as the man that
actually gave us our favorite series of
Star Trek in a very long time and he
might not be available to do this he has
signed on for a couple of projects over
at Disney and fox and he might be too
busy but they may have a plan B and that
plan B is Jonathan fraks he is already
front and center on lots of projects
he's directing a loads of strange new
worlds and I hear that he will be the
main man if they bring back Legacy he
will obviously be directing and probably
appearing to a degree but actually there
will be another showrunner working with
him and that basically he will be sort
of a co- showrunner so let's see what
happens I'm hoping Terry mat talis's
schedule isn't as full as it looks if
you look at his IMDb because I am
absolutely certain if he is able to do
this and if Paramount phone him he will
be in a taxi and R to par Studios
instantly that's fingers crossed that
they do get him and they do get Jonathan
fraks and they get really a dream team
that they got for Picard season 3
because Terry metalis does understand
what particularly us slightly older
trekkies want and some people call that
fan service I say giving the fans what
they want is just sensible business
because when on Earth did it become a
bad thing to actually make your
customers happy but guys get into the
comments and tell me what you think do
you agree with me and the sources that
I've spoken to that this was always the
plan that we really shouldn't be
worrying about Star Trek Legacy because
it's definitely 100% happening and like
our rafy said as soon as they're done
with Academy they will start working on
Legacy or do you think no we've not been
lied to we will only get Legacy if we
make enough noise and don't get me wrong
we need to do that too because Paramount
needs to be confident actually that
enough people do want to watch Legacy
which is probably another reason why
they do this they sort of you know tease
us with it and then we have a campaign
and that gives them then plenty of
evidence to sort of figure out how many
people then watch the show when it comes
on so it's not a bad way to get that
metadata that they all seem so desperate
for
nowadays but is it honest is this
actually something we're only going to
get if we make a big enough noise get
into the comments and tell me what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out you'll
never miss any of our new videos also
you can go to patreon.com sidre where
most of our new videos do premere first
and you get to see them without the
adver you lucky bunnies also you can get
to s.o. which is our dedicated website
and we do articles based on a lot of our
video
we try to add a little bit more
information there for you to digest too
so go check that out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time